hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
I'm Jim J Roz and this is Tamra's never
seen and today we are watching home
alone rather reluctantly right yeah not
looking forward to it
yeah I've avoided this movie my entire
life I feel like most of the movies i
watch I'm like well I haven't seen it
yet but it turns out great um so you
never know it's not the vibe I infer but
it could be stellar man mm-hmm it could
be really good
uh-huh Doug and Rob Walker are making us
do Shirley um yes I would not be
watching this probably uh partly out of
principle I guess because I was like I
avoided it when I was young as when we
came out and I was like in junior high
and every single kid in my school had
seen this movie and like even the kids
that like one of my buddies who didn't
want to see the movie felt a movie so it
was like and none of my siblings are
right like saw it so it was kind of like
in protest yeah a little bit like I was
like I really just didn't want to see it
but they want everybody else saw it I
was like I definitely I'm gonna see how
it is
cheers Cheers oh wait oh you have to do
a hair flip
oh yeah well intro okay yeah we do the
same thing okay yeah yeah one two three
I was so sad that was good
yeah kind of feel like
sorry guys yeah yeah yeah didn't I
didn't hate it
uh um but nothing has changed hi I'm
gonna leave here completely unaffected
and ten percent it was exactly what I
expected yeah well I will say I for all
these years I just assumed that the
entire movie was like them trying to
break in the house and them all like
they're ridiculous so yeah so in a way
I'm relieved that it wasn't that because
I'm like holy shit that's gonna get old
after like ten minutes that's true yeah
there wasn't a lot of that it only
lasted 10 minutes so good time and that
wasn't the more enjoyable part of the
movie for sure yeah highly unrealistic
Richard I think I had like a kill count
like you know like the they should have
died at least four times like iron to
the head knows those those slips on the
steps were pretty rough mm-hmm are you
like you're surviving yeah you could sue
the bad maybe I mean yeah baby okay so
the movie opens up and it is just chaos
there's so many kids I didn't know who
these people were uh Joe Pesci is a cop
just standing in the middle of the house
he's inviting yourself in yeah no shit
in the house like yeah there's a knock
on the door whatever it's just a house
with chaos in the police officer all the
kids unaffected by police I grew up like
super afraid to get in trouble so I
would have been like super nervous -
nobody pays attention like even the
adults are like not the pizza guy in
Joe's that the pizza guy shows up they
go to have their meal and they leave the
cop and the pizza guy just in their
damning yeah like I guess we'll have
their super rude all of them are so rude
and unlikable and I guess that's the
idea is like whatever you're like so he
wishes his family away so you don't feel
like mm-hmm but of course why when you
wish them well there's awful awful
parable here yeah but he's kind of shit
he's like this creepy little fifty-year
yeah right fuck around in his pajamas
and it's a row sober yes
know how I remember the 90s anyway like
yeah but I didn't grow up rich wait so
like if a little rich dude is left alone
and like all of the things that he sets
up and it's like how where'd you get a
thousand pounds of feathers your prayers
just had those lying around like bang
tough that the pillows I guess goose
feather pillows pillows yeah that was
super unbelievable but because he made a
mess of the house and then at the end
it's beautiful man right but are on the
stairs I think like might as well Maslow
move the stairs let's take care those
stairs out there it's not salvageable
one of my favorite parts though is the
old man who has this really intense
stare every time you see him done dinner
crazy stare Schilling eyes and he
doesn't say anything I would be
terrified of him so that makes it that
make sense yeah I thought it looked kind
of a sweet old man that I'm like he was
horrible yeah give that guy a hand with
your shoveling and poor guys out there
all my insulting so here yeah he's salt
in the sidewalk so they're like he's a
killer music yeah
sweary cute bodies murder is over in
that home but then he doesn't off the
show the guys at the shovel so god I
hope you're a murderer I need to know
right now they're gonna bite my goddamn
fingers off and touch my head yeah so
really on threats yeah I'm a fight
you're progressing you're sure you know
yeah to a kid just because it's at a kid
it's like creepy like if you're like in
a big fight with like a person your age
like I'm gonna bite your fingers off
that's kind of scary but till I tell a
little kid that you're gonna bite his
figures off individually is that's just
so weird
I loved though when the robber got his
head blow torch because he just stood
there
yeah right
the acting it's pretty rough rough
specifically from ik illegal yeah yeah I
mean I never thought he was a very good
accurate but um I was told that in this
film like it's like he's pretty good it
was after this that he kind of sells out
and you know it's just kind of like
phones it in what have you seen him in a
book he was actually pretty good not
good luck I will say that that was
pretty home alone okay oh pretty humble
oh yes oh that is there's a giant candy
it's a it's okay okay
insect Oh uncle okay I know what it is
yeah yeah okay you see that thing that
him in Leonardo DiCaprio had where
Leonardo DiCaprio were a shirt with him
on it and he were shirt with a picture
of Leonardo DiCaprio wearing the shirt
of him I like that yeah that's good
that's all you know about Macaulay
Culkin then he's a great guy
things he sets out for the burglars
after ends um one I understand
loving this if you like saw this as a
kid yeah because those are the kinds of
things you seen like cartoons and like
that would be so fun to accomplish and
do and he said he does it without a
hitch right right
he's very confident when he's like I got
about 10 minutes for his rappers get
here I got about 12 booby traps I get a
sense it would take at least a day at
least a day I'm gonna make myself dinner
light some candles you can have a nice
meal before I unleash L on these messes
yeah like he is like a fight yeah he's
gonna grow up to be a psycho killer yeah
it's his lips his lips are they freak me
out okay so there's the water that they
slip on great that even it is easy
enough the iron brutal but if done well
easy and easy cuz it's like it's rigged
to the goddamn white so you pull this
the light so either like disconnect that
light bulb hitch or that or the string
would ever attach it to this line is
going up the yeah dumbwaiter or whatever
it is that's you know that's true yeah
I mean it could happen but it was just
it would take a lot of time any of these
things like it's like in the movies all
the time it's like let's you know do a
montage and then it takes me here days
yeah yeah the char right that Shh
well while doing some major damage to
the house is effective oh oh well the
tour choice rigging that torch that
would take some time like I'm telling
you I'll tell you I don't think your
words um yeah that would that would take
a little bit uh he was super confident
that it wasn't gonna just like kill this
anyway right or light the house on fire
ya know like you put that like uh
whatever that hot iron or whatever like
on the doorknob you know it's like that
in the door nod heat it up to the point
where it's like glowing red but it
doesn't send your burn the door at all
what your side like oh the feathers and
it's like a like he turns effect like
the fan goes out and immediately it
doesn't kind of start up it just goes
and looks like I just I mean also it
just didn't stop him from doing anything
I just took them off ornaments by the
door or the window it was pretty bad
like oh that's only bad if you know
you're coming in barefoot mm-hmm you
know right now a lot of plans a lot of
plan he's like well first I know I'm
pretty sure they're gonna go downstairs
in the basement and get their shoes
stuck on the tire I didn't know when
they come back they're gonna come
through the specific window because we
shot from this window once before and
hopefully he'll jump down a really hard
hit that right both feet it's very
diverse yeah and then he doesn't like
scoot he just gets up and walks right if
I didn't step on this one though the
spider on him led to the great scream
yeah I will say that was that was pretty
good
uh-huh I did like a scream Allah and the
zipline oh yeah across the yard it would
have taken what the hell I like I feel
like so unnecessary right right that's
another like kid dream though to be like
personal you have a tree house that's
amazing people you're gonna supply the
house to the tree house incredible yeah
I guess up I had seen this movie when I
was like in grade school like fourth or
fifth grade and probably what if Evelyn
like
like we're into it that's the problem
with coming to some of these older
movies now it's like I get why it was
like right I understand but I and I get
I didn't mean like vote yeah I miss I
miss the boat I feel like any time
there's a Chicago shout out and a movie
is like oh hell yeah yeah and some nice
cameos from some some other key like
John Candy and the guy who plays the
Santa I don't know what his name was but
he was in a lot of movies yeah he was in
like money Groundhog Day and stuff it
was like the annoying guy on the stairs
Dubrow huh
that's a future episode coach Rob Walker
kept saying that the only like downfall
of the movie is Macaulay Culkin like all
the side characters are great and I do
think they were yes yeah all of them yet
like me yeah exactly character actors
and stuff we're good and you they're
like cool she went through yarn is good
but still fun and got him watch it was
like not as good as one you gotta watch
two and three no no that's it I thought
I might do two next year we'll continue
this tradition oh yeah so if I'm doing
it you have hey oh there's no cats Ike
isn't here
oh yeah well shit didn't even have a
sorry hi
well three two one mine didn't make it
all the way oh that was a thing but we
did we did yes it was tune in next year
for home alone - oh we have to do this
oh yeah that's true
which is actually another really
annoying thing because that was like so
overdone
like everything ever gave me commercial
and ITV show and shit like period II
that and I still don't get I don't know
why that's not funny yes he was yeah is
that funny I think the thing about him
was funny you know no like running into
the camera and screaming ah
you know like running around the house
and like you know sped up motion and be
like ah yeah it's not funny here and I
think like when I saw that in the
trailer like that was like enough for me
I'm like I don't care I'm here to see
that
I don't want to see this as a kid I was
like excuse me that's such a Jim thing
to do I don't care about this yeah I'm
not gonna watch that me see that junior
high so everybody everybody is like what
were you talking about it you have to
see it everybody has seen it I know I
don't like this I'm not into this then
it's not until years later until the
Walker brothers are like no you have
they know they were they were very
animal intense about it yeah and ferb it
like for like the last two years ever
since they found out that I never
thought like no you have we ever going
to tie you down to a couch this holiday
and make you watch it they were also
saying that that we were gonna cry at it
right that was never gonna happen right
I was I wanted to get I was I didn't
want to shoot there you know shoot there
getting sound right away it was good I
enjoyed it I I did not like it but it
was I can't say I enjoyed it
that was a strong choice of word yeah I
also said it was good at first they were
a few moments I thought that the the
stead brother character yeah like that
by even the buzz thank you
it's funny a kid is funny he's hilarious
yes yeah and he has a giant mouth right
she's a his expression some kids
delivery and everything I was like all
right he's sold it yeah yeah I like so
much then the angels with dirty faces
movie which in the movie like I oh I saw
that I was like this movie I just want
to see this noir film this looks amazing
mm-hm yesterday I released a video on my
personal channel Tamara L chambers know
which one was fucking suck
check it out you did it but check that
shit out check out the home alone
version of awesome builds which ship is
gonna make the feather board yeah I'm
gonna more efficient one though with a
leaf blower and see how it works with
you Mythbusters episode that would be
actually that would be super than ever
done that's a great idea I should I
should do that that's a great idea
I would totally watch that I'm never
gonna do how
Missy holiday holiday and Hanukkah
whatever and everything that you does
not hurt Kwanzaa yeah yeah whatever man
enjoy yourself uh go watch a good
Christmas movie rapist Yeah right what
is it yeah loved that I didn't see them
oh it's good oh yeah yeah it has been
Wyatt in it oh yeah so it's great can't
go wrong
hi guys
[Music]